bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti nella mia
casa gigantesca che ho fatto io mi sono
fatto un culo talmente per la strada che
ci ha dormito un mese non ho portato
video perché appunto il mio personaggio
di minecraft era troppo occupato a
dormire in side the house che il povero
fernando si è dovuto mette a giocare a
carte con i poveri lama ma di amarci che
stanno qua da un mese anche loro ma
l'ambiente è casalingo bello accogliente
proprio perché oggi eviteremo un nostro
amico che è tornato dagli inferi non si
sa che non si è capito dov'è la ma ce lo
spiegherà lui al momento al momento
giusto che è il buonissimo amico pietro
che qua con noi dopo due anni che non
avviene sul calcio pietro affinché mi
sono perso soprattutto sei lontano dal
microfono di 6 persi camera tua 96 di mi
ricordo 9 sono sono su un albero
ma che cazzo fila su un albero sono
dietro di te
ecco mi soddisfa mi sa dire con i bomber
che fermando già un miracolo se mi porta
via senza scalciare gli fa bene
io vorrei lasciare per terraferma ratio
e fernando però se lo dobbiamo tornare a
prenderla fernando no non lo lascia mai
seguirà allora basta che mi dici perché
io qui vero tante bellissime cose qua
allora aspetta allora oggi portiamo il
nostro amico pietro rimuovere mondo
degli hotel per un anno tokyo chiude a
posto tutto a posto troppo fernando è
abituato fanno d'abito il nostro amico
pietra da un sacco di tempo che non
vedeva le le bellezze insomma di fare
video con col fa vi è quindi ti mostrano
vacis la metà delle cose che ci sono le
so manco di tipo quell'astronave tipo
aliens e come l'ha fatta marcia occhio e
croce quanta strada ha fatto sto server
così poco tempo a priori forti adesso
bordello quami che vieni verso di me
ecco però questo che sono qui ti faccio
vedere la casa più bella di tutte e la
mia ovviamente mi faccio vedere qual è
il momento di far vedere a pietro la
casa la casa che conta
puoi vedere da lontano una casa di
satana è la tua casa di catania ma stai
scherzando
è mia perché mi chiedesse sembra
bellissimo un anno e mezzo ma non ci
credo l'hai fatta tu al motore fatta io
mi sono impegnato ma c'è un modo davvero
f.to pene spect la vedi quindi per e
spect subito anche chi entra in questa
mirabolante casa partendo dal sentiero e
come è un po rosso fernando sia stato
quel mese e circa un mese prossimo
ci vuoi del pane ma io vorrei io ho fame
amico e rivale persone importanti ma
scusami ma è rimbalzato poi guardato
bene grazie
allora questa questa è casa mia vota
faccio vedere ma che figata
questa roba meno 1 3 2 3 2 gulacsi in my
house prima di entrare di suonare la
campanella no di casa che fuori
suona st campanella poi niente ma si può
entrare ma richiama alla polizia facile
come facciano ad abidjan al pari del
coni sempre che la caffarella chi se
frega di nola la porta
questo posto è uscito the tranquillo lui
non sa come si sa la campanella che si è
mangiato cielo non mi parla roma la casa
mia che cazzo fai dovesse perdere con
gioia ma cosa fai di primati all'europa
questo rimando lascia stare
divertitevi al piano di sopra che si
sale con questa casa comodissima scala
abbiamo un divano di merda che ho fatto
io effettivamente questo togliere fa
veramente schifo al piano di sopra
abbiamo l'ascensore l'ascensore vieni
qua mi che l'ascensore funzione che tu e
marino e ti spara flash a in alto però
attenzione che poi al nono posto
sbagliato porta sbagliata che mai e
l'altra porta perché quella ti porta giù
se non ami che sotto sotto sotto però
secondo via bravo bravo
no non posso dire adesso non posso
discendere le saline
ecco un amico mio grazie va benissimo
questo ascensore volte ti devi abituare
di avere allora qua abbiamo lanciato in
table
ok non è tanto di sapere ad al baida
questo tutti i libri scritti da alberto
angela
personalmente non sono incastro come
come se come si esce se avessi letto i
libri o sapresti guarda qualcuno che non
lo sa non lo vede però è ma se c'è un
passaggio segreto esatto ma che ogni
passaggio segreto che ti porta all
in cui linea gli anvil che puoi fare
effettivamente robe bene continuiamo il
nostro tour
simpatico il nostro amico pietro andiamo
lì sopra amiche vieni qua ok si prende
cura ci sono qui ma che figata così ma è
bellissima storia va a casa molto figo e
ci ho messo tanto farle comunque il
fatto che non so perché non affidare la
figura mi ha detto d'oro fa sempre
effetto c'è anche il piano di sopra si
dice che sia prevedere la cosa più [ __ ]
ok ogni sopra è roba randomica tipo qua
e le cause l'hanno interrogato bella
casse nelle casse esatto è vicina questi
fiori bellissimi abbiamo il ponte no
mamma bellissima dal mio punto di vista
sembrava che ti fossi schiacciato per
terra ma io ho chiuso la porta e siccome
questa è una dinamica ma scusi va bene è
bellissimo perché fischia guarda come la
guarda come ti ho vista dal mio punto by
wire e rialzo schiacciato era bellissimo
il morso per per da sola bravo
bellissimo si vede tutto anche il b con
vedi tutto quanto ok rumores a 7 fervidi
tutto quanto pesa mia tesi scemo
utilizzando questa dinamica
dell'appiattimento se tu entri qua
dentro e poi gli schiavi per terra vuoi
strisciare nei condotti e guarda cosa
c'è in fondo vedere una casa segreta una
casa segreta che ora non è più segreta
perché lo sai la lista va bene allora
siccome sono magnani
non avevano né costruiti la tua
casettina perché anche tu inizierei
ovviamente a far parte di questo mondo
la v vanilla mentre costruiamo casa tua
iniziamo a prendere i materiali perché
studio a casa tua ha sbagliato dove
arrivano i soldi dove qua qua c'è un job
adesso vediamo
spiegami che cacchio di successo che ha
deciso di non fare più vivere soci
dietro ci spiega perché ha deciso di non
fare più niente quindi spiegarci perché
tutti che non avete litigato ma che
succede se tu sei tu cerchi su quel che
è successo
trovi che si è strafelice e pietro senza
che niente perché la gente non ha capito
perché l'abbia stessi file insieme come
si fa allora praticamente c'è io e loria
abbiamo litigato ma non è vero adesso di
e cacciaviti non è vero non è
assolutamente gli uomini perché allora
prima di tutto siamo rimasti sempre in
buoni rapporti non sempre giocato
insieme sempre parlato ho sempre fatto
cose belle insieme è nulla se non perde
un po brutto smesso di fare video ma la
cosa più importante è che siamo tornati
a picchiarlo re grazie ma non la voglio
però una spada li chiama lei preto 4
spalle e tra le tre troppo bello insieme
allora io viene nuovo 18 questa risata
di pietra che contenta di fare video con
me che torneremo subito in grande stile
con un bel minecraft parkour nei
prossimi giorni una nuova serie seguita
da tutti quanti la registreremo tra
pochissimo quindi tra questi giorni
uscirà mai craf al qurbi aspetto li e
pietro ovviamente inizierà a fare video
anche quattro di barilla per continuare
a casa sua che continua a fare video
insieme quindi iscrivere anche il suo
canale che vi lascio in descrizione e
nel mentre che diciamo queste cose noi
siamo pronti perché io ho preso un po di
roba mica fare una casetta nuova e
allora ma se non altro sotto per vedere
se c'è qualcos'altro e possiamo prendere
perché noi potessimo farla cadetta nuova
ma io voglio una casa bella tipo c'è più
bella della tua allora si chiama ditta
edilizia marci la panda marche marco ci
lavorano
io lavoro a casalpusterlengo io poi
faccio quello quindi effettivamente per
ora ti puoi permettere
favi jpt fa la casa non marcia quando
march sarà disponibile col suo
calendario
potrai farti fare la casali donald trump
siamo usciti anche di mattina che culo
visto almeno 12 che restano non lo so
adesso coordinate manca la seconda
coordinata
ma i fatti sono che discorso private si
chiama march chiamarci vodafone servizio
gratuito di numero chiamato non è il
momento raggiungibile visto lo sapevo ma
c'è un cavallo d'ossa mi che qui c'è un
caso ma i fatti
scusami ma prendi una sella poi qualcosa
che in casa la sella subito è che lo
troviamo ad un amico un amico magro per
fernando vedendo è mica è difficile non
vederlo fino a trovare assolutamente una
roba per il cavallo una sella qualcosa è
che gli chiediamo se c'è mark non vedeva
stop restar c'era adesso aspetta un
prezzo andiamo da mark e senza
chiederglielo e glielo chiediamo lì di
fianco perché ci puntiamo a casa tua e
aspetta che vado a controllare nella
roma segreta di che mi servirebbe per il
cibo fatto un attimo eccola qua che
stavo cercando l'annuncio la sella però
trovato un'altra cosa molto simpatica
prego di milione per picchiarmi quella
cosa è andata bene ciao ragazzi usa sta
roba
devi buttarti da qui amiche amiche sono
contento il tuo bene lì tra i cavalli e
io vado a piedi
no aspetta aspetta quello arrivo lavato
arrivato in bollo da lui ma simbolo da
lui e io punto arrivò scusami da the way
mi chiami sono schiantato su un albero
mentre scrivevo che male che male
qualche botto libere mentre guidi non
scrivere mentre voli non rischiare
l'haier niente ma che cazzo ha messo
meno note ragazzi sto morendo non ci
credo
io sono morto da marx è pazzesca sta
roba
macché ma che cacchio cia fuori di casa
mark ma per quale motivo di gag e di
andar lì che ci ha paura che gli indù
invadono i barbari ma cos'è tn ires
chimica una sella da prestarci e con per
restarci intendo regalarci
ma secondo lei è che ce ne sono io non
ho una sella ma come non è una sella ai
una sera regalarle grazie ecco l'abbiamo
trovato ragazza vediamo ma i cataloghi
si faceva montare ma non credo
aspettando il fine ma solo prendere che
sono non solo prende anche la felice e
innamorata di me perché dato il fieno
talking ma scusami vedeva il mio
cavallino vuole bene ma scusami lupi il
cavallo ma che vuoi ti aspetta togliti
vabbè non mettere le cose prima
mettici la se siete bravi che mai scusa
mi va bene grazie vetrato però
permettermi di nomina permettimi di
nominarlo almeno non solo fino stupro e
con un foro il nome brutto come si fa e
serve la nate dogg di mettere il vendere
nel land pil nominale
ok buy in via ai un livello ok nomi
nella questo cavallo volti nello per un
bel po posso guardare dai l'altra
fernando queste fermare la forza allora
c'è una nave
però a mente c'è questi solo sei amiche
a me piace queste gesta qui questi dove
siamo adesso mi devi spiegare tutto però
vabbè ce n'è tanto da noi dipende cosa
vuoi fare
no no no no penso che non c'è l'isola
tengo tolgo tutti gli alberelli ok se
facciamo una bella casa qui sopra
secondo me è molto molto bella brava
bene e allora va bene allora il
parcheggio fermando qua ma non su cui
sopra ma parcheggiano qui sotto fernando
qua sotto fernando e iniziamo a fare le
cose
va bene let's go vale ragazzi questo era
il video con il nostro amico pietro che
tornando a fare video grassi amica che
si è tornato nel prossimo episodio
vedrete che faremo la casa together che
prese piso che sarà sul cane di pietro
perché davanti si fa anche se sulla biga
nella ma sul mio canale ci sarà mycroft
parkour very very very very very soon
quindi ragazzi non perdetevi manca il
colpo che sarà incredibile come le serie
vecchie se vi ricordate sia i signori
grazie all'istituto vino iscriviti al
canale a ciò detto mi piace e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo vito bella
ragazzi
[Musica]
no